ça s'arrête je n'ai pas pour méfait ou
même une petite fille pour ces femmes
autochtone de val-d'or
le secret était devenu trop lourd à
porter elles ont accepté de nous parler
des abus dont elles sont victimes des
mauvais traitements que leur ont fait
subir depuis plusieurs années certains
policiers de la sûreté du québec régis
labeaume a débarqué du chat après mon
cas prime ça que j'avais deux galdin
mais ma petite de biens et primo cela il
a même morceau acheté ma mon seul adam
sacoche avec claude vialade base et il
m'a poussé
je tombais un tapis a pris part de mr et
lâcheté d'un bal de neige ce qu'ils ont
fait est mort le soleil soit partir on
allait semaine en bois de faire sa
relation aux autres
on a eu combien de policiers comme ça
n'était pas la seule
non je pour la seule
mais chacun 200 pièces
c'est un ps pour pour le servir piste en
place que je ferme ma gueule
di bello je vois jouer les projets en
tenant du poste de police
les montées avec lui oui oui moment
montré une salle de l'intégration il m'a
dit moss est ce imad il m'assure que la
tap il ne descend du pantalon puis je
sais ça j'avais 19 ans sans jamais
parler d'autres savants ça pour la faute
au temps pas pourquoi sortir soupire
surtout vais y débite faire milles 9,6
par rapport au politique pourrait aider
d'autres jeunes aux autres d'autres
jeunes femmes qui vont peut-être vivre
même la même chose le cajon marcil est
barmaid à val d'or elle en a vu et
entendu des choses
s'ils ne font pas d'évaluation des blue
job en bon québécois l'as des blue job
chiffon posso ils sont ils sont ils font
massacrer l'arrivée des claques des
bleus dès coups de poing et des brûlures
dans fondent à taipei ce poste une femme
active et non 15 20 personnes exécutiez
directrice générale du centre d'amitié
autochtone de val d'or
si ça se passe ici à val d'or jeunesse
qui se passe ça me plaît et je me
demande ce qui se passe avant jeunes en
substance à toronto
et puis un moment donné mais c'est assez
c'est assez
les élus c'est assez leur accessible à
la suite de notre passage à val-d'or la
sûreté du québec a été mise au courant
de certains comportements de ses agents
quatorze dossiers ont été ouverts pour
des allégations d'abus de pouvoir de
voies de faits et d'abus sexuels donc
vous avez identifié certaines personnes
effectivement il ya eu huit policiers
qui ont été rencontrés tous les dossiers
seront somme sous contractant des
processus des poursuites criminelles et
pénales et à ce moment-là on pourra voir
la suite des choses
il ya une semaine après de multiples
hésitations l'une de ces femmes
priscilla pas pâti est venu au bureau de
la saq à montréal identifier son présumé
agresseur
celui qui l'avait abandonné sur une
route loin du centre ville la nuit en
plein hiver sa photo est à l'heure de
jeu les reconnaissances de gaza
qu'est-ce que tu réaliseras des femmes
qui ont peur des représailles la police
c'est ce qui est bien d'apollon ce ne
sera jamais
josée dupuis radio canada montréal